Colin when I look at st. Louis I think
of delmar boulevard why is delmar
boulevard different than any other major
street of divide in any other American
city I think I mean st. Louis is a
remarkable city for a history of
segregation partly because I mean I
would characterize and Louis is a city
that Southern in its race relations but
northern in its organization of property
and so there's a stark segregation
reinforced by all sorts of private and
public policies respect to deed
covenants real estate practices that
created this sort of this iron divide
between african-american north st. Louis
and and white south in loops there is
the arch which shows that expansion of
America continue on that what is the
difference for example between st. Louis
and Detroit one of the remarkable things
about st. Louis which is playing out in
the inner suburbs like Ferguson today is
that it's remarkably fragmented
metropolitan area and so there are there
are over a hundred incorporated
municipalities in st. Louis County alone
that have over the course of the last
entry poached the city of st. Louis of
it fiscal capacity of it wealthier
citizens of its very population
professor Gordon we're trying to
understand how we got here in the first
place and and is it possible to actually
point to specific policies whether their
zoning policies or whatever that enabled
this kind of effective segregation to
happen yeah I mean I think it is really
a chain of policies that began you know
st. Louis is one of few cities that
tried early in the 20th century Dutch
the explicitly zone property is biracial
occupancy that was struck down by the
supreme court but what followed was a
very meticulous set of practices by the
real estate industry reinforced by
Missouri law which placed covenants on
deed and confined the african-american
populations very closely to the north
side of st. Louis
and these covenants were were systematic
across the city and even more so in the
suburbs as a way of sort of checking the
growth of the african-american
population professor Gordon I want to
bring in the angle care of the
militarization of the police my morning
must read is from two members of the
friends Committee on national
legislation they write in the New York
Times that for a police department like
Ferguson's the path to becoming a
paramilitary force is a short one after
loading up with free military gear it is
no surprise that law enforcement agents
want to use it there's been a lot of
government funding post 9-11 to local
police departments how is that
exacerbated the tension that already
existed in Ferguson well I mean I you
know you have what is in some respects a
classic story of American cities which
is a confrontation between an African
American population in a white police
force and yeah I think you put it very
well when you when you militarize that
when you when you give these ball
communities that sort of capacity the
overreaction is some is predictable
entirely predictable professor I'm sure
you're aware of Thomas shellings
important work on segregation and race
from the early 1970s where the professor
talks about a small movement in people
ends up being a larger segregation isn't
that what's going on in any community in
America today yeah and I think you know
for much of the latter half of the 20th
century it was a pattern of segregation
by race and that's been displaced
somewhat by a segregation by income
which is growing starker and starker and
cities like st. Louis oh so critically
you would suggest in your research
professor that the segregation of 2014
is decidedly different from 1963-64 no I
would not be decidedly different I would
say it's a reinforced more by by
economic means that now than by
explicitly racial ones but the
underlying pattern is substantially the
same